[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée au projet dure envers le
projet nuremberg c'est l'adaptation
théâtrale des minutes des procès des
médecins nazis qui ont eu lieu entre fin
46 et août 47 adaptation sous l'égide de
la faculté de médecine et de la faculté
de droit de l'université de versailles
saint quentin alors c'est un projet
passionnant ce à trois points de vue
d'un point de vue historique puisque
c'est la première fois que les minutes
de ce procès sont traduites d'un point
de vue universitaire puisque c'est une
collaboration je le disais entre deux
universités la faculté de médecine et et
la faculté de droit et il est vrai que
ces procès pose des problèmes de
médecine d pour le même juridiques et
des problèmes éthiques et puis projet
passionnant aussi sur le plan de
l'enseignement puisque peut-être que
cette adaptation théâtrale est aussi une
nouvelle forme d'enseignement est en
tout cas unis très étroitement les
enseignants et des étudiants pour en
parler d'y aller un âne bonjour vous
êtes professeur de médecine vous êtes
doyen de l'ufr simone veil de santé
mari et ma bourse y est beau jour vous
êtes la doyenne de la faculté de droit
deux piliers de cette de ce projet vous
êtes vous êtes à l'origine de ce projet
on va en parler dans quelques temps
quelques instants n'a dit younès bonjour
vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
vous êtes psychiatre vous êtes chef du
service de l'hôpital mignot père ça y
est vous avez évidemment participé de
près à ce projet et
diète de clermont-tonnerre bonjour
conjoint alors c'est vous qui avait
adapté qui avait écrit
aussi vous allez mettre en scène ce
spectacle qui aura lieu ce mardi 26
octobre à la faculté je suis pas tout
seul il faut pas oublier quelqu'un de
très important qui est sympathique qui
est voilà je dis on a signé sept co mise
en scène et ce travail autour du procès
absolument et vous allez nous parler
d'adaptation évidemment et puis en visio
avec nous et xavier paoletti bonjour
bonjour je ravi d'être avec vous elle
vous êtes professeur bon vieux
statistiques à l'institut marie curie et
vous êtes beaucoup intéressé évidemment
à ses procès vous allez nous en parler
et puis deux étudiants lucas le mou qui
est étudiant en droit
bonjour
et charlotte laurent vous êtes étudiante
en médecine et vous êtes depuis
l'origine dans ce projet je crois
justement on va aborder le premier thème
de cette émission c'est le procès des
médecins nazis et est évidemment comment
est né ce projet nuremberg
[Musique]
1-1 à nantes je vais commencer par vous
parce que je compte vous êtes à
l'origine de ce projet il ya eu un
voyage ou en 2019 à dachau à nuremberg
et c'est là qu'est née l'idée de ce
projet l'idée du front non l'idée du
projet est né avant et en fait c'est une
aventure pédagogique avant toute chose
qu'on mène ensemble depuis maintenant
plusieurs années et avec l'idée de
baisser de transformer la façon dont on
transmet le savoir à nos étudiants dont
on leur permet d'acquérir un certain
nombre de compétences d'une façon on va
dire un peu moderne est davantage centré
sur notre société et donc l'idée de
prendre des sujets importants de notre
société et de voir au travers de
l'histoire
comment on peut contextualiser ces
sujets et les apps les appliquer
finalement trop vite tous les jours et
permettent à nos jeunes étudiants de
construire de façonner une approche
sociétale est donc pour eux qu'ils
soient un moment important de leur vie
aussi un c'est assez déterminant à la
fois dans la façon dont ils vont
apprendre leur futur métier et aussi
dans la façon dont ils vont finir par se
comporter on espère au sein de la
société donc on avait commencé par la
reconstitution du vote de la loi sur
l'avortement oui si mountain et on avait
donc vu avec cette première expérience à
quel point la mayonnaise prenait bien
entre et les étudiants et les
enseignants et ça a été une expérience
tout à fait magnifique puis ensuite on a
eu cette réflexion collective pour
essayer d'établir une suite quel est ton
faire ensuite et bien assez rapidement
la question du droit des personnes du
droit des patients est apparu comme un
sujet très fédérateur et puis du coup la
réflexion autour de la reconstitution du
procès des médecins nazis du procès de
nuremberg
pratiquement 75 ans après le ce procès
se soit déroulé voilà comment une
histoire
a démarré et donc on s'est dit avant
toute chose il est essentiel de faire ce
voyage à la fois dans le temps et dans
l'espace en se déplaçant ensemble pour
aller voir concrètement
l'atmosphère qui régnait dans ce camp de
concentration
et puis
au sein même du tribunal qui existe
toujours et qui est toujours en activité
et donc ce temps là qui était consacré
exception des noues un canton durant ben
voilà le fait d'aller sur place
évidemment
dachau il ya bien évidemment ça change
les perspectives ça permet de visualiser
d'appréhender davantage la question et
ça a été je crois un élément qui a
encore plus renforcé chacun dans la
conviction qu'il fallait faire chaque
projet le mérite mais bon c'est
justement alors tant que vous ne voyez
de fait que des doigts 7
regards croisés des médecins et des
juristes c'est important oui c'est
essentiel alors d'abord la
transdisciplinarité c'est essentiel
toutes les disciplines dans toutes les
disciplines et puis je crois que c'est
la démonstration aussi du fait que le
droit aujourd'hui et on me l'a toujours
été à l'articulation de tous les sujets
de société et donc dialoguer avec les
médecins sur des sujets qui ont cette
dimension historique de formation en
effet de l'esprit civique des étudiants
je crois que ce que ça leur apporte
c'est au fond le voyage le dialogue la
confrontation c'est un recul par rapport
au contenu qu'on peut leur apporter une
mise en forme et puis je crois un débat
aussi
entre eux avec les metteurs en scène
avec avec les enseignants-chercheurs et
qui je pense leur apporte beaucoup en
terme de maturité aussi je crois que
c'est ça fait partie aussi notre rôle
vous étiez de deux voyages
ça serait intéressant d'avoir votre
point de vue justement vous avez été
vous êtes jeune étudiante
vous êtes donc je crois que c'est quoi
au quatrième et des noms
d'un important pour vous d'être là bas
de caisse qui qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti dans deux voyages alors la
première partie du voyage ça a été la
visite du candidat hao qui en fait le
premier camp de concentration mais en
place par le régime nazi et je me
souviens de cette journée qui était une
belle journée avec un beau ciel bleu une
belle journée de novembre mais une
journée très glaçante dans une ambiance
très très silencieuse et on a vu
plusieurs choses dans ce camp tout
d'abord en arrivant une grande grille en
fer forgé avec l'inscription le travail
rend libre qui était un slogan largement
utilisée par les nazis a posé devant la
plupart des camps et puis
entre sur une très grande place immense
place où était en fête réunit tous les
matins les prisonniers pour l'appel et
c'était très bizarre de de fouler cette
place au 21e siècle impunément
normalement puis après découvrir des
énormes baraquements en bois où étaient
entassés des centaines de lits
superposés
où tout le monde dormait dans des
conditions vraiment
horrible et puis là à la fin en fait on
a terminé par le crematorium
qui était vraiment difficile à avoir
avec toutes ces pièces en enfilade ou en
fait on a suivi le parcours c'est à dire
la première partie où les détenus
étaient invités à enlever leurs
vêtements pour aller prendre une douche
je suis là les fausses douche qui était
jusqu au carrelage comme des vrais
douche je suis les quatre fours à la fin
c'était vraiment glaçant puis certains
étudiants ont même ça est insoutenable
pour eux
et puis la deuxième partie du voyage
c'était la visite du palais de justice
de nuremberg gh qui était donc
l'ancienne capitale idéologique du
troisième reich et c'est dans ce palais
de justice dans ce qui est resté des
banques ont eu lieu les célèbres procès
est donc la première partie c'est un
musée qui est très didactique qui a été
fait pour expliquer toutes les
spécificités de ce procès hors norme
parce que c'était quelque chose qui
échappait à tout ce qui avait trait tout
ce qui avait été fait auparavant en
termes de droits ou me semble et puis à
la fin de la visite on arrive devant une
petite vitre qui donne sur une salle qui
est donc la réelle salle d'audience
souvent lieu ces procès une salle
majestueuse
très belle en fait
un peu plus petit peut-être que ce qu'on
s'imagine sur les photos et sa salle
d'audience d'ailleurs est encore utilisé
aujourd'hui pour des procès pour des
colloques
donc voilà tout ça c'était très fort et
ça a permis de bien poser les bases
alors
revenons à ces procédures à bahia le
procès de nuremberg coco n'est plus que
le procès des dignitaires nazis
kaka lieu des 45 et puis il ya ce
procédé des médecins je crois qu'il ya
vingt-trois personnes qui sont qui sont
dans le box des accusés dont vingt
médecins il y aura plusieurs panaria
quelques acquittement il ya aussi neuf
peines de prison lourdais cette
condamnation à mort
il ya alors les minutes du procès c'est
énorme n'ont ni les nations unies
alors pour nous effectivement d'un
projet ce qui était important c'était de
partir de ces minutes alors les minutes
ce terme c'est ce qui a été dit les
paroles dites par le président l'avocat
l'accusé qu'est ce qu'est ce qui a été
dit qu'est ce qui a été dit non 7 à ce
moment 46 47 et comment nous maintenant
en les lisant en 2021 ça va certaines
paroles vont être datés certaines
paroles sont d'une actualité frappante
est évidemment beaucoup de paroles
frappes ponctuelles étaient frappantes
ont été gardés dans la pièce dont il
fallait partir ces minutes et ses 12 11
mille pages je veux pas été traduite en
français alors déjà elle était pas si
facilement d'accès minutes parce que
quand nous sommes allés au tribunal de
nuremberg nous avons demandé eux mêmes
des militants d'anglais et il n'était
pas présente donc ça a été un peu un jeu
de piste entre guillemets pour trouver
déjà ces minutes en anglais
dans les effectivement penser qu'elles
étaient traduites là le mémorial de la
shoah elle en avait pas trace dans les
universités de l'université de caen
avait traduit une partie mais pour le
procès des dignitaires nazis et pas le
procès des médecins finalement un
enseignant de notre université olivier
plus n a trouvé les minutes numérisés
sur le site de l'université d'harvard d'
american et accessible là on a trouvé
les onze mille pages
qu'est-ce qu'il faut bien dire aussi
c'est que ce procès
ddd médecins de survie il intervient
après le procès des dignitaires oui il a
lu entre décembre 46 et 47 deux voitures
inscrit dans une série de 12 ce procès
douze autres procédons qui elle mais le
procédé des médecins nazis mais on va
aussi avoir le procès va déjà liste le
président et militaire et s'est donc
c'est une série ensuite de 12 entre
procès qu'on appelle les procès au fond
c'est ceux qui ont un peu mis en oeuvre
la la la solution finale un tout
l'hexagone dont la pratique quoi de ça
donc ça doit être assez assez frais il
ya une parole du du procureur je pense
dans ce procès qui dit parce que c'est
vrai que c'est on se pose toujours la
question est ce que ces gens là étaient
des sadiques
et lit pas forcément que c'était des
gens d'ailleurs on le verra dans la
défense qui vont prendre ou dix on obéit
aux ordres c'est un peu ça mais dit non
c'est pas tous des pervers so so so so
so vous pas des hommes ignorant la
plupart d'entre eux sont des médecins
qualifiés et certains sont d'éminents
scientifiques quand vous lisez c'est un
pur des savanes évidemment ça fait ça
doivent toucher bien sûr encore une fois
on pense science comme étant au service
de l'humanité et non patience comme
étant destructrice de l'humanité et donc
la finalité de la recherche qu'elle soit
médicales ou autres
devraient être essentielle à tout
médecin tout chercheur alors la vraie la
vraie question départ c'est quand on
voit par exemple les personnes qui ont
été acquittés c'est la connaissance
que pouvait avoir certains des médecins
chercheurs entre guillemets de la
finalité de leur recherche
est donc
puisqu'ils ont été jugés et acquittés on
peut concevoir que effectivement
certains d'entre eux n'avaient pas
conscience de la finalité des travaux
qu'il menait et de ce à quoi et vous
allez servir après malheureusement
beaucoup d'autres avaient une parfaite
connaissance de la finalité de la
recherche est pire que ça
souhaitait même pouvoir exceller
dans cette recherche oui c'est ça avec
une finalité tellement morbide que ça en
devient très angoissant quant au lit
alors il n'était pas au procès puisque
l'huile à échapper à la justice mais
quant au livre sur ma gueule par exemple
on s'aperçoit que c'était plutôt un bon
médecin mais comme ce comme souvent
souffrent mais c'est donc aux mères de
famille heure et demi que ça leur donne
tout d'un coup cette possibilité de
faire des expérimentations sur l'homme
une sorte de puissance à laquelle ils ne
résistent pas comme s'il y avait une
croyance absolue dans la science au fond
qui dépasse tout
oui pardon
quelqu'un voulait intervenir nom
nadir younès peut-être là-dessus sortimo
de puissance peut être senti oui le
sentiment de puissance et puis de
progresser la salle c'est là c'est là
que s'engouffre la place de l'éthique
coquelles qu'est ce qu'on fait de
2,2 du pouvoir qui et comment les tic va
limiter ce pouvoir vous mettre un cadre
pour rester dans quelque chose de
raisonnablement acceptable est
effectivement là il y avait plus
d'éthique ça qu on a dit que suite à ce
procès nurenberg
la naissance de la bioéthique qu'on
appelle la bioéthique vient du procès
n'avait pas volé dit il ya eu quand même
énormément de victimes
du fait des de ses médecins nazis
les innocentes victimes du fait de ses
médecins nazis notamment
pour tous les programmes de sélection
des
sujets considérés comme étant inapte
néanmoins dans le cadre de ce projet
nous sommes focalisés nous avons plutôt
priant le parti de choisir une
expérience ô
le nombre de décès est probablement
limité même si c'est assez terrible dire
ça comme ça parce que justement ça
posait une question de l'expérimentation
humaine sans tomber dans l'horreur
absolue
de l'élimination systématique et dans le
cadre des patients qui ont été dans des
sujets qui ont été inclus dans cette
expérience sur l'eau de mer il ya eu
propres produits ont l'expérience aucun
décès probablement un ou deux décès par
la suite
oui mais ce qui est intéressant aussi de
devoir c'est de replacer les choses dans
ce contexte la plus plus générale et et
peut-être que xavier pour en reparler
encore un petit peu dans un instant
parler un peu de la question de
l'idéologie qui va être à la base de
toutes ces expériences menées mais il
faut savoir quand même que alors c'est
ce qu'ont écrit les historiens que les
médecins se représente un groupe
professionnel extrêmement nazifié oui la
plupart sont nombreux toutefois du parti
nazi
ça représente deux tiers des médecins ce
qui est ce qui est ce qui est énorme
alors est ce qu'il y a voilà peut-être
des choses à dire xavier aussi sur cette
question de l'appréciation idéologique
il ya sûrement une conviction de la part
de ces médecins qu'ils oeuvrent dans le
sens du succès du reich et on le voit
dans les argumentaires de la défense
même si on peut pas exclure une mauvaise
foi terrible
ils ont je pense comme beaucoup de
scientifiques la certitude que leur
action scientifique sera bénéfique aux
soldats allemands qui sont sur le front
de l'est aux marins qui sont abîmés en
mer à un certain nombre de personnes et
dans certaines remarques dans cette
intonation on est surpris de voir à quel
point leurs réponses sont décalés par
rapport à l'horreur de ce qu'ils ont
commises et qu'il laisse suggérer qu
effectivement un certain nombre de ces
scientifiques et comme pro le mans et
d'un monde scientifique quelle que soit
l'époque fit perdre un petit peu le le
sens commun aux airs annan
réagir la question de relation entre le
médecin et le politique d'une certaine
façon pour dire que ce n'était pas une
exception le troisième reich ou depuis
pau crac et depuis le début de la
médecine la médecine a toujours été au
pouvoir proche du pouvoir soit utilisée
par le pouvoir avait faim variés soit
parfois influence ont le pouvoir donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
surprenant et on le retrouve aujourd'hui
la présence des médecins
dans les assemblées au parlement et
proment accord qui est très représentée
oui mais le miz de la sautée de médecins
par exemple le sénateur mûriers qui est
à l'origine de la première loi en france
sur la recharge de l'éthique recherche
médicale étaient en néphrologie et est
médecin et si on ne revient au médecin
nazi
il ya peut-être c'est peut-être un peu
caricatural ce que je dirai donc comme
toujours quand c'est caricatural ça peut
être mal interprété je ne le souhaite
pas mais il ya quand même eu deux
aspects différents dans l'action de ces
médecins chercheurs entre guillemets
nazis il ya ceux qui ont oeuvré pour
faciliter l'extermination
des juifs il ya ceux qui ont une vraie
ou dont la finalité de la recherche
était de trouver le meilleur façon de
faire
et cela honnêtement c'est quelque chose
qui est absolument
absolument et puis il ya ceux qui ont
vraiment travaillé sur des questions
comme celle qui a été reprise à la
représentation théâtrale ou l'arrière
pensée était de 10,1 paradoxalement
c'était pour sauver la vie des soldats
allemands qui se retrouvèrent en mer et
dont il y avait une question
cliniques pertinentes ou dans la
finalité était plutôt de sauver des gens
que de provoquer l'extermination et
c'est un peu ça qu'on retrouve dans le
procès des médecins nazis on voit bien
que le
juges ont fait cette différence entre la
finale et ceux qui avaient véritablement
mis leur savoir et leurs compétences
pour une extermination diabolique et
ceux qui ont un vrai comme des médecins
et chercheurs avec la finalité qui à
tout médecin de d'essayer de soigner de
prévenir et d'aider les autres et même
pour cette deuxième catégorie quand même
le crime contre l'humanité enfin oui
quand même souffrance
dans la tv il faut jouer les oies
neuvième siècle à moigné qui commence à
poser les bases d'une justice pénale
internationale pour lutter contre les
crimes contrôler les gens m'appellent
droits des gens et puis churchill leur
donne l'impulsion pas le traité de
versailles en 1919 essaye d'instaurer
une juridiction pénale internationale et
finalement à l'initiative de churchill
et sous son influence n'est ce statut
spécial du tribunal militaire
international de nuremberg donc c'est la
première juridiction avec le thé ennemi
de tokyo qui en effet créé les principes
du droit pénal international du droit
des gens de protection
vraiment intéressant parce qu'on va on
va créer les principes en même temps
qu'on va juger la 4g des notions kling
notre droit le
l'importance de l'atteinte à la dignité
fait qu'on a considéré que c'était
finalement des infractions immanente qui
existaient parce que le droit des gens
justifiait la protection de nos
caractéristiques les plus les plus
humaines les plus absurdes et jouent un
jeu et voilà c'est quand même moins les
passer en termes juridiques de haut
niveau sensiblement si je peux dire oui
c'est certain mais il y avait quand même
des obstacles juridiques fort qui était
notamment liée à la rétroactivité de la
loi pénale the et de pub où la norme 3,8
et nous protégeons nous en tant que
citoyens voilà d'un pouvoir exécutif ne
parlait pas y voir de l'air exactement
révélé en fait voilà l'été immanent dans
le droit pénal nationale et il est
révélé donc il n'est pas rétroactif que
soit le crime d'agression entre m contre
la pub le crime contre l'humanité voilà
donc ça c'est intéressant aussi sadi le
consensus autour de ses activités on va
passer dans un instant à l'expérience
que vous avez choisi éco hôtel pour le
pour eux pour l'adaptation théâtrale un
mot quand même sur la ligne de défense
de ses médecins en gros c'est on a obéi
aux ordres est bon on peut penser que
c'est de la lâcheté absolue mais en même
temps est-ce qu'on peut demander à des
des gens de médecins d'être des héros
alors où est ce qu'il faut être un héros
pour dire no 20 millions il faut être
est ce là pour dire donc encore une fois
peut être médecin voilà oui c'est à dire
que finalement ce qui prévaut lorsque
l'on est bête ça d'une certaine façon
c'est le serment d'hippocrate
c 'est le premier la première référence
à laquelle
dans laquelle on se tourne et dit assez
bien les choses c'est à dire que un
médecin ne peut pas eu de vraie contre
l'intérêt de la personne qui se confient
à lui quel qu'en soit le motif est donc
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a inventé
le secret médical qui permet justement
un médecin de ne pas
révéler des choses sur son patient qui
pourrait lui nuire et ça quelle que soit
la contrainte même s'il peut y avoir des
dérogations justice c'est à dire que le
droit pénal organise cette obligation de
ne pas répondre à un ordre que ce soit
dans le cadre militaire ou plus
largement dans le cadre d'un pouvoir
exécutif contraignant ce qu'on appelle
l'ordre de la loi le commandement
légitime qui exonère un militaire d'un
acte qui serait illégal à la limite près
qu'un acte dit manifestement illégal
ne doit pas être un ordre manifestement
illégal ne doit pas être respectée sous
peine d'engager sa responsabilité pénale
donc la limite est là et où il une halle
de milieux rimbert les juges ont bien
d'expliciter que
un crime contre l'humanité ou tu ta
toute atteinte révélées par ces
infractions étaient manifestement
illégal et donc il ne pouvait pas y
avoir d exonération de la responsabilité
quelle que soit sa place et son lien de
subordination
dans l'accord la ligne hiérarchique
ce que je veux dire aussi fringant tous
ces principes dans une démocratie on
voit bien comment ils peuvent
s'appliquer dans un régime comme le
régime nazi c'est peut-être plus
compliqué de dire non je dirais et c'est
pour ça que la distinction que vous
faisiez vous paraît assez pertinente
parce qu'il ya en effet ceux qui
participent à la solution finale puis ce
qu'ils disent peut-être je ne sais pas
on pourrait imaginer bah oui je suis
allemand je défends les soldats
allemands
le procès est absolument troublant et
c'est que on on ne peut pas s'empêcher
de se mettre à la place donc le moment
parler de notre ville m beagle boc qui
est le médecin puisqu'on est parti du
général pour aller vers le particulier
c'est à dire que sa ligne de défense
c'est mais moi j'avais un pistolet sur
la tempe ma famille était en danger et
c'est extrêmement troublant parce qu'on
ne peut pas s'empêcher de se dire si
cher sa place voilà et c'est là où tout
le travail de l'accusation est assez
exceptionnel c'est qu'elle remet en
contexte en disant vous aviez des
solutions et c'est ça qui est absolument
troublant parce que le procès n'est pas
spectaculaire c'est à dire qu'on
s'attend à avoir un peu comme un film
hollywoodien des effets de manche il
laisse dans la banalité du mal c'est à
dire que c'est évidemment un mari et sa
fille c'est troublant de le relire parce
que ce sont des médecins de comme tu
l'as dit de très bons pères de famille
était de très grands médecins qui avait
un grand sens de tourisme de l'éthique
il ya aussi un poids constant il ya dans
le dans les minutes du procès qu'on
rejoue théâtralement un personnage qui
s'appelle le docteur hans épinière qui
est une espèce de mandarin le médecin
qui était une espèce de génie
deux voix là dedans et tous ces
étudiants tous ses assistants sont
fascinés par ce et donc le médecin
conquis jugé n'arrête pas de dire j'ai
obéi à mon professeur qui était un grand
médecin et qui si celui-ci et qui s'est
suicidé mais ça c'est extrêmement
troublant content cd système de
hiérarchie et les systèmes de en disant
ce type est le meilleur chirurgien quoi
donc je veux dire il a raison il faut le
faire et c'est il dit six professeurs et
une guerre disait cela ça devait être
vrai si on était un peu une emprise
dans les liens aussi et une leur système
de défense qui est assez étonnant c'est
de dire aussi nous l'avons fait dans les
meilleures conditions que qu'on aurait
pu le faire dans un hôpital ils ont ils
vont jusqu'à cette horreur là en disant
voilà on l'a fait de façon la plus
correcte possible ils s'estiment exclus
au fond un rouage au sein d'un système
très puissant et on obéit aux ordres
c'est comme le dit à la reine longtemps
procès est le procès eichmann au fonds
s'attend à voir une bête monstrueuse et
puis on voit que
c'est pas ça c'est un fonctionnaire
assez médiocre et le east of persia
médias mais c'est comme ça que ça marche
ailleurs
justement je leur dirai ce que je disais
dt2 de clermont-tonnerre la la la force
d'un d'un professeur de médecine par
rapport à ses étudiants quand vous
voulez vous avez vu ces procès ça vous
pose une question personnelle
d'attention je vous fais attention à ce
qu'ils disent ce qu on fait ça osa
question de l'exemplarité mais l'exemple
parce que le les étudiants
comment dire agissent volontiers par
mimétisme et cherchent le plus souvent à
reproduire ce que leurs enseignants
fait
remarquer absolument et donc c'est donc
il se positionne la référence la norme
est effectivement ce que son enseignant
déploie et donc si la norme élaboré par
l'enseignant débouche sur quelque chose
de très mal et l'étudiant
pourrait
effectivement ne se laissait c'est
presque de l'endoctrinement et c'est en
ce sens on ça n'est pas normal c'est à
dire que ce mimétisme
singer reproduire ce que fait son
enseignant doit avoir comme limite le
discernement du bien et du mal c'est à
dire de dire ouh là là il me demande de
le jeter par la fenêtre mais non c'est
pas ça n'est pas raisonnable je ne vais
pas le faire et donc c'est cet élément
là qui est important pour nous si on
revient à la pédagogie enseignants et
doyen d'essayer de de développer au sein
de nos facultés de nous assurer que
cette relation entre enseigner
enseignants reste bien dans un cadre
éthique et déontologique alors on va
vous dire
l'expérimentation qui fait le coeur de
cette adaptation théâtrale s'étant
défait vous l'avais un peu évoquée pour
venir au secours de souad marins soit
deux pilotes qui serait
seul au bord de la mer et qui n'aurait
plus que de l'eau salée à ce qu'il faut
peut-être aussi dire c'est que c'est une
expérience parmi de nombreuses
expériences là aussi où l'utilité entre
guillemets apporté à la luftwaffe elle
est peut-être un peu à peu moins
prégnante je pense par exemple à des
expériences sont menées sur le paludisme
typhus destinée risation du mas
des collections de 212 squelette de
déportés juifs pour pour étoffer la
collection de la faculté allemande de
strasbourg donc oui voilà on a on a
quand même aussi un grand nombre de wii
d'expérimentation et nous on en a choisi
une et nadir el nour el nous expliquer
des expérimentations qui sont ceux qui
se sont fait dès 1939 jusqu'à en 1944 et
donc effectivement on a choisi une aussi
parce qu'elle s'est passé à dara au
puisque c'était important nous avions
finalement il n'ya plus le lieu
on s'est posé la question ce qui est le
lieu reste non fixée dans l'espace
et donc cette expérience c'est celle de
cmc ces naufragés ceux qui n'ont plus
d'eau potable est ce qu'ils peuvent voir
l'eau de mer c'était comment peut-il
survivre le plus longtemps possible tant
que petit pc de secours est secouru et
donc ils vont monter une expérience avec
un protocole un peu ce don expérimental
avec cet objectif de voir quelle quelle
qu'elle survit avec l'eau de mer est ce
qu'il faut prendre des petites quantités
d'eau ou pas du tout et puis il ya deux
méthodes qui qui s'affrontent
avec un médecin docteur schaeffer qui a
réussi à rendre l'eau de mer potable en
enlevant les motocycles mais c'est très
onéreux ça demande beaucoup de faire
c'est pas forcément réalisable et un
ingénieur schaeffer qui lui dans lève
que le goût de l'eau
enfin le goût du sel donc ce qui est
assez terrible c'est que les personnes
peuvent voir ses taux mais avec
énormément de conséquence sur sur la
santé sur la santé jusqu'à jusqu'à les
convulsions jusqu'au bout mais s'est
noyé quatre groupes il ya quatre groupes
un qui naquit qui n'a pas d'eau 1 qui a
de l'eau de mer un qui a la méthode
berck à un cas la méthode schaeffer avec
intense avait été déjà fait sur des
quatre jours sur des volontaires ça
avait déjà été fait chez les hommes les
animaux ne pouvaient pas être utilisées
fin c'est ce que parce que c'est pas le
même métabolisme donc les aider et les
validations et donc il expérimente sur
quatre groupe de tziganes
adhara eaux qui sont soumis surtout ceux
qui boivent l'eau de mer et ceux qui
ce signal et a soif qui est terrible
paris il en a conscience docteur villa
madame qu il leur dit vous allez avoir
la soif ça va être terrible
on est dans un camp de concentration et
et toute la discussion absolument
nauséabonde de la pièce et sur cette
question du volontariat avec évidemment
l'accusation qui n'arrête pas de dire
mais comment l'on reparlé de volontariat
dans un camp de concentration et et ça
touche à des questions par exemple les
on a vraiment l'impression de de deux
laboratoires qui se pardonnez moi
l'expression qui se tirent la bourre
berka d'un côté et schaeffer de l'aude
et ça ça nous parle énormément
aujourd'hui puisque derrière il ya quand
même un énorme budget de faire la ration
d'eau afin de trouver la solution et une
économie et donc il ya aussi très
concrètement et ça ça ça résonne
aujourd'hui le fait qu'il ya deux voies
lâché faire et berck acquis vraiment
sondés ya ceux qui ont des appuis
politiques dans la ss d'autres à
d'autres endroits
mais économique de deux entreprises vers
cas il veut absolument que ça soit son
ca méthodologies qui soient pris par la
luftwaffe parce que c'est un marché
économique énorme à ce moment là dans
une économie de guerre de celle du du
troisième reich donc c'est là où ou ceux
où ce procès est absolument vertigineux
dans son écot encore
contemporain quoi dans lequel et zafy
paoletti justement sur cette
expérimentation
ce qui est étonnant c'est qu'ils
essayent de l'allier à travers justement
la recherche biomédicale quel con pour
aide à connaître maintenant avec des
groupes contrôlent avec une évaluation
qui se veut la plus objective possible
avec des conditions expérimentales qui
sont décrites quand on voit leur rapport
que michael boch envoie ses supérieurs
hiérarchiques
c'est assez glaçant alors récemment il
ya une dizaine d'années il y a eu à sa
tempe de de recherches qui ont été
faites publiés dans des journaux
médicaux comme de nuit une glande disant
que ses expériences dans la côté
scientifique ces expériences c'était
juste une fumisterie mais on voit quand
même et c'est ça qui était passionnant
que derrière l'aspect expérimental
finalement pourra passer des choses
absolument horrible qui sont de
soumettre des gens à la soif et comme le
rappelait nadia le décale book annonce
assez pâle à ces sujets que la soif est
une des choses les plus terribles qu'on
puisse endurer qu'on va devoir les
enfermer qu'on va devoir d empêcher de
demander à boire doigts d'obtenir de
l'eau parce que c'était une pulsion
vitale absolument rêve donc il ya
des aspects scientifiques
finalement on fait accepter des choses
absolument horrible et je serai pas
complètement surpris que wendel blog
soit convaincu effectivement d'avoir
mené l'expérience du mieux possible
parce qu'il suivait il le redire
plusieurs moments il suivait des règles
de la recherche biomédicale si on peut
l'appeler comme ça même si c'est
totalement
détournées mais voilà il ya sept
il ya ce souci là et juste pour faire un
parallèle
il n'y a pas très longtemps
les gens se posaient la question de
savoir si pour pouvoir accélérer le
développement de vaccins contre la copie
de 19 il fallait pas infecter un stand
de deux volontaires avec un virus pour
pouvoir obtenir plus de cas et on voit
que rapidement les tic entre dans cette
question du protocole expérimental pour
répondre à des questions scientifiques
il ya parfois un combat face à autre le
entre l'impératif scientifique et villa
de latif et éthiques ils sont restés
combien de temps voire
six jours des jours 6 si je vous dis ça
peut être mortel aller jusqu'à 12 jours
il savait que c'était mortel
les pathologies des fonctions de foot du
foie c'est ça alors que certains ont
effectivement dans le protocole dont on
parlait xavier certains ont eu des
fonctions hépatiques
on va parler voilà on va pas c'est
formidable on va passer juste voir ce
deuxième tome c'est donc l'adaptation
théâtrale
[Musique]
alors vous le disiez un petit peu quand
on fait de l'adaptation théâtrale où on
passe du général au particulier parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on peut identifier
s'identifier aux personnages en tout cas
le comprend mieux leur psychologie
exercice et il est un peu périlleux
parce que déjà ce procès il écrase un
peu il écrase parce qu'il la
fantasmagorie qu'on peut en avoir donc
on était très humble par rapport à cette
matière et on a vraiment fait avec toute
l'équipe et je dis tout le monde un
travail à la fois de lecture parce qu'il
a fallu traduire ces onze mille pages et
puis il a fallu faire des choix je
dirais difficile pourquoi plus cette
expérience là que celle là pourquoi plus
ce set c'est voilà et des coupes c'est à
dire que je le réduis ce n'est pas le
procès de nuremberg des médecins nazis
que vous verrez tout à leur nom c'est
des extraits
usa des rumeurs oui ça dure une heure et
donc c'est ce sont des choix qu'on a
fait collectivement suite à tout un
travail dramaturgique qui a été très
important puisque les étudiants comme
sarah et moi on a eu plein
d'intervenants qui sont venus nous
expliquer la différence entre le droit
français le droit anglo saxon puisque
c'est un procès américain puisque ce que
je n'arrête pas de dire aux étudiants il
faut qu'on comprenne ce qu'on est en
train de dire pour que vous ayez des
chances vous spectateur de comprendre ce
qu'on est en train de vous raconter donc
le premier travail dramaturgique c'était
de ébats de comprendre ce qui se disait
de d'essayer de voir aussi les problèmes
de traduction c'est beaucoup
voilà posé ces problèmes là parce que on
joue une traduction ce n'est pas
en anglais qu'on joue en france est donc
comment on trouve ça et ensuite
on est parti donc d'un état des lieux
c'est à dire les premiers jours du
procès parce qu'il ya des discours
important des juges qui remettent
l'historicité et surtout la conscience
des américains que c'est un procès
extrêmement important parce qu'il va
poser on va en parler évidemment des
règles de bioéthique mais c'est un
procès de vainqueur et ça il faut aussi
leur questionner c'est à dire que ce
sont les américains qui revisite
l'histoire est écrite par les vainqueurs
exactement et là on a des moments dans
le procès
assez étonnant puisque la défense des
des médecins nazis il ya un fond et un
célèbre défenseur stein bauer qui lui
même avait été avait eu des démêlés avec
les nazis donc il a eu cette force aussi
de défendre des gens qui l'avaient
opprimés et ça c'est un symbole de nos
démocraties être capable de donner et
bat n'importe qui même à celui qu'on
considère comme un monstre une défense
et ça les américains étaient extrêmement
précis en disant il faut une défense
parce que les russes voulait fusiller
tout le monde les français n'en était
pas loin et oui équitable et ça c'est
bon il faut il faut quand même le le
noter donc il ya tous ceux se complète
d'un vrai procès un véritable procès et
évidemment on s'est amusé avec ce
cérémonial c'est à dire que vraiment
aujourd'hui un procès c'est un
cérémonial c'est une mise en jeu d'un
moment il ya cette très beaux mots du
temps suspendu du jugement qui est dit
il ya de très beaux très belles prises
de parole à la hauteur de l'événement on
sent que les juges notamment le juge
taylor est quand même quelqu'un qui a
une hauteur de vue et qui sait qu'il est
en train de faire quelque chose qui va
résonner dans l'histoire donc on est
quand même sur des paroles ou jeudi aux
étudiants il n'y a pas grand chose à
jouer il faut être à ce qu'on dit et il
faut essayer de vous le donner pour que
vous l'entendiez que ça résonne qui est
un travail très difficile parce que
peut-être parler avec les avec lucas le
loup et laurent lucas bardon presque
entendue comment vous êtes arrivé dans
deux projets et qu'elle est calé vous
votre rôle
alors moi je suis arrivé dans le projet
parce que j'avais déjà fait donc le la
reconstitution de la loi veil -le il ya
trois ans et en fait du coup j'ai
participé dès le début de ce projet je
pense que ce qui a été plus difficile en
tant qu'étudiants et ce qui est encore
difficile c'est la lourdeur des paroles
qu'on doit prononcer en particulier pour
la défense ce qu'on a quand même des des
discussions assez abjecte sur est ce qu
un gitan et un asocial par exemple ou ce
genre de choses et c'est assez difficile
à prononcer donc trouver le ton juste
comme des 10 ne pas sûr jouer vraiment
trouvé le le bon ton c'était quelque
chose de très difficile et l'autre chose
qui est aussi très difficile c'est de
réussir à retranscrire le sens parce
qu'on a une parole qui continue sur
plusieurs étudiants qui provient de la
même personne et réussir à transmettre
ce feu c'était aussi un défi et je pense
qu'on a réussi à le relever en tout cas
jusqu'ici
je sers l'autre clos
oui je rejoins totalement lucas surtout
ce qu'il a dit et je voulais aussi
ajouté que pour nos étudiantes et
étudiants c'est très intéressant de
participer aussi à ce projet théâtral
sur le plan de l'éloquence et de
l'hommage courant à ce thème en fait qui
est très bien très justement abordé par
l'équipe pédagogique
vous savez bien que justement c'est
d'expérience pédagogique faisait oui
c'est ça manque et je crois qu'en même
temps nous à la fois dans l'est dans les
facultés de santé et aussi le droit de
faire travailler nos étudiants soient
prises de parole médecins infirmiers
sages femmes il n'y a pas que des
médecins dans le projet
doivent prendre la parole parler avec
les familles et nous chez nos juristes
plaidé parfois pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux dont je crois que c'était
vraiment le temps de mettre l'accent
aussi sur ce travail des locaux c'est de
le croiser avec avec la médecine avec le
droit et c'est compliqué mettre en scène
des fours des et c'est pas des
professionnels
on travaille toujours de la même manière
que ce soit des professionnels ou des
étudiants ou des amateurs sur être à ce
qu'on dit la notion de respiration aussi
d'arriver vraiment l'articulation donc
on a vraiment on est reparti sur des
pourrais vous raconter sur des
fondamentaux ont fait des échauffements
que le corps soit voilà disponibles les
couteaux si ce n'est pas évident c'est à
dire c'est pas parce que tu es en train
de parler que que tu n'es pas en train
de parler que tu ne joues pas souvent tu
va éclairer celui qui parle pas parler
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va dire exactement
par qu'on écoute donc c'est aussi ça
c'est comme ça qu'on a formé aussi un
groupe qui mêle des étudiants qui au
départ de l'aventuré ne se connaissaient
pas du tout été sur des on va dire des
champs de connaissance assez différent
médecine droit et comment un moment
chacun a apporté en fonction d'eux parce
que finalement ce procès c'est une
espèce de gouffre auquel on sait tous
penchés avec nos petits savoir les uns
et les autres et des étudiants nous ont
aussi éclairé comme nous avons éclairé
les étudiants ccsa ce que j'aime dans le
théâtre c'est à dire de réunir un groupe
autour d'une question qui était ce
procès et comme en bas on essaye
d'avancer ensemble avec ce que chacun
peut apporter et c'est ce travail moi je
suis assez enthousiasme de nature mais
c'est ce que je retiens de ce travail
indépendamment de la représentation de
ce soir qui est encore une autre
aventure comment ça va être voilà
comment
ce soir 18h cec ou
le fait que de bottines sa seraient
captés il ya une captation qui va c'est
presque c'est un peu triste que ça ne
soit joué qu'une fois non mais c'est pas
là c'est une première représentation
montataire terrain avec le producteur
pour voir comment les étudiants vont
réagir et après c'est une tournée
internationale nous rassurer a bien sûr
non mais il ya vraiment l'idée que c'est
une première et c'est les yeux après ça
fait partie du projet on choisit souvent
un lieu très emblématique par rapport à
notre question il ya surtout une chose
qu'il n'y aura pas ce soir qui est très
importante c'est qu'il ya un débat avec
des personnalités parce qu'il est
absolument nécessaire
quand on travaille sur cette matière là
de donner la parole à des gens qu'il est
clair qu'il à remettre en contexte qui
nous qui nous aide à mieux la comprendre
donc ça ça fait vraiment partie d'une
deuxième étape donc c'est une première
et hop hexagonal s'est rassuré voilà
alors voir celle d'être dernier thème
puisque on le disait du rebberg de
naissance du crime contre l'humanité
c'est aussi la naissance de la
bioéthique
[Musique]
j'ai pas des bêtises
contrôle
c'est alors c'est quoi la blague
bioéthique justement
[Rires]
parce que je me disais tout à l'heure et
dit s'il ya qu' on a fait croire enfin
dit dans le procès servent à 10 étaient
des volontaires
étaient c'était pas des volontaires mais
la question de la volonté et du
consentement les centrales elle est
centrale et ce qui est ce qui moi me
fascine d'une certaine façon c'est que
cette position qui ce consentement aux
soins de la personne elle est placée au
centre par hippocrate
une 3e siècle avant jésus-christ dans le
cerveau ordinairement dans le corpus
hippocrate y retrouve vraiment ce
fondamental c'est à dire que je ne doit
en aucun cas nuire à mon patient
et puis il va s'écouler beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de temps
et il faudra des histoires très triste
comme celle de l'extermination des juifs
et des médecins nazis pour que on voit
apparaître dans le droit international
dans les textes modernes va dire qui
régissent la santé ou d'autres cette
notion du consentement d'abord dans la
recherche
de code de nuremberg déclaration
d'helsinki quand même en 1964 et puis
ensuite on voit apparaître probablement
la france a été dans les pionniers je
pense que la loi huriez en 88 est
probablement l'une des premières lois en
europe qui consacre 7 cette motion
pour terminer peu juste pour terminer
question après vous poser c'est que dont
88 donc va il aura fallu longtemps qu'on
introduit sa dans le droit pour la
recherche médicale et curieusement il
faudra attendre la loi kouchner vingt
ans après quasiment pour introduire la
notion de consentement aux soins c'est à
te dire bah non elle soigne on ne peut
pas le chien mâle avaient apposé à soit
une personne si la personne n'est pas
d'accord
la criée notable c'est que la médecine à
la parole en premier parce qu'au fond le
droit ensuite est rattrapé par ses
questions interroger les jugeons suprême
sont interrogés et au début ils ont été
très réticents à se prononcer donc on a
consulté la cour de cassation les
gouvernements consulter des comités
éthiques puisque c'est une question
sociétale peine quelques juridique et
après le droit intervient pour essayer
d'accompagner au fond et on le voit là
de façon depuis mary d'une vingtaine
d'années historiquement avant nuremberg
la question des expérimentations sur
l'homme les pas traitées il existe des
règles coutumières communément acceptées
mais il n'y a pas deux
premiers cadres mais
dans l'histoire de la médecine le cadre
et les expériences il est
l'exemple et d'envoyer cette notion
alors on retient souvent que les bons
côtés
sur mes mais cette notion oui cette
notion niveau testé sur l'oeil les et
pour faire avancer la science est une
notion qui du point de vue médico
scientifique est tout à fait pertinente
laisser alpes pas m on a eu tout ce
débat avec le lay rennes messager et où
il ya plein d'artistes mais comme on a
mis sur le marché quelque chose qui n'a
pas été testé sur l'homme justement oui
mais le danger pour moi c'est qu' il ne
faut pas demander aux scientifiques
d'établir ce qui correspond finalement
aux limites au périmètre de la recherche
est à la société de le faire c'est à la
société de voir ce qu'elle étendre ce
qu'elle veut accepter ou pas pour faire
avancer pour faire avancer la science et
la science médicale et donc pour faire
avancer in fine est la finalité globale
de la science médicale de la charge
médicale c'est de faire avancer
d'améliorer le bien-être des gens au
delà même de la santé d'allonger
l'espérance de vie de vivre avec une
bonne qualité de vie c'est ça la
finalité globale et donc les règles
c'est bien la société de l'aide de les
fixer et pas aux scientifiques si on
prend un champ tout à fait récent qui
est celui de la chirurgie des gènes
fabuleux crise peur cazeneuve
barbarisme médicale
qui a valu à une française emmanuelle
charpentier le prix nobel de médecine il
ya deux ans mais comme elle le dit elle
si elle était restée en france elle
n'aurait jamais pu mener ses travaux de
recherche est donc aujourd'hui ses
travaux de recherches qui ont été menées
à un moment où la réglementation
française avait bornes et la recherche
médicale pour empêcher ce type de
recherche voyez que c'est très compliqué
parce que le très cool et partie du
cours aux états unis pour pouvoir mener
ses recherches et qui aujourd'hui
représente une avancée fondamentale pour
la santé et non seulement la santé mais
aussi la santé animale et on va aller
dans un monde où ces questions de plus
en plus se poser je suppose non
c'est extrêmement fragile aussi parce
que il ya quelque chose qui dans notre
découverte qui était extrêmement
troublant c'est que la médecine
allemande avant le deuxième conflit
mondial et la médecine qui se pose là le
plus les questions de consentement
éclairé du cobaye et c'est la fille du
livre qui fait date voilà qui pose tout
ce qui va être la loi de bioéthique
d'aujourd'hui donc ça veut dire que tout
ça est extrêmement fragile et qu'il
suffit qu'il y ait une ville 1 1 je
dirais un environnement politique qui
remettent ça en question pour que ça
disparaisse en même pas à 1939 jusqu'en
43 donc on ça c'est vertigineux de se
dire que toutes ces questions elles sont
voilà extrêmement délicate fragile art
questionné en permanence et qu'en effet
c'est une décision avant tout de la
société pour borner le scientifique
quelques barons en tout cas pour
l'encadrer sa cession et quand vous
dites
recherche était possible aux etats-unis
et pas en france est-ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas au besoin d'une
décision un peu internationale sur ce
thème là parce que si on peut trouver
toujours ailleurs on peut pas faire et
quelque part il y aura toujours des
apprentis sorciers dont vous alors sans
doute pas le cas de deux
voiliers mais il existe des tels des
taxes internationaux la déclaration
d'helsinki ont bien s est vraiment un
fondement important de la recherche
biomédicale en europe il existe un
règlement repères sur la recherche de
techniques sur les médicaments et
produits assimilés donc il y à des
textes internationaux
relatifs ficultés moi me semble t'il
principal c'est quand même celle du
consentement
parce que il ya plein de sujets dans le
consentement éclairé d'une personne
c'est jusqu'à quel point il est éclairé
et que faire des personnes pour
lesquelles malheureusement le
consentement n'est pas possible ça veut
dire mon trône et prenait la maladie
d'alzheimer prenez la démence donc si on
attaque malades d'alzheimer par
définition il est difficile de consentir
de façon éclairée alors ça veut dire que
ont banni toute recherche dans la
maladie d'alzheimer et donc on se prive
de toute avancée dans la prévention le
traitement et la guérison de cette
maladie donc c est donc c'est là où il
ya des choix de société à faire c'est la
société de décider si on y va aussi on y
va par ge
question de l'euthanasie on se retrouve
face à la situation il ya un jeune ou un
soin ou une volonté de la part de
l'individu et que la loi limite cette
possibilité et puis le moment du
consentement et le moment de l'acte ne
sont pas toujours sont pas toujours liés
donc ça pose des ddd problème est-ce que
d'une façon générale mais c'est une
question plus philosophique que je pose
est ce que quand la science permet
quelque chose on n'est pas tenté de
finalement de d'y accéder la france est
pour l'instant on ne dit pas ça we dance
à 5 ans qui est ce que finalement ça
pousse si je pense à tous les évolutions
je pense que il ya au moins un exemple
qui vit à l'esprit où finalement
la volonté de la grande majorité de la
communauté scientifique a devancé le
droit qui maintenant existe qui hélas ne
sont de clonage
allik là ça va faire bientôt presque 30
ans que
la brebis dolly a été cloné et dont vous
voyez que
l'âme est la médecine la science
aujourd'hui
rend tout à fait technologiquement
possible le clonage humain non c'est
fait technologiquement c'est possible
si on ne le fait pas en 2004 le code
pénal introduit une infraction donc la
neige productifs qui est interdit par la
loi donc il ya une réaction au
foot mais précédé
la littérature médicale de très
nombreuses sommités médicales sont
prononcés par des éditoriaux dans des
grandes revues sinon attention là on
atteint des limites de la science ne
doit pas franchir et donc ça a permis de
devancer troyen risque de privatisation
de tout ça se dire il ya peut-être des
gens milliardaires et divas qui vont
avoir recours en dehors des lois et
c'est aussi à des risques on est
malheureusement un email malheureusement
on sait rester des heures avec vous mais
alors on va renvoyer déjà à ce qui se
passe ce soir à 18 heures à ce qui se
passera y avait hier de la captation
donc j'espère pourquoi voilà il paie
surtout dire elles sont quand même
combien on a des étudiants sur scène ce
soir on a 25 étudiants donc voilà il ya
du monde
300 spectateurs c'est une grosse
production
se soit fait choix et il y aura et ce
n'est qu'une première étape c'est ce que
j'ai retenu merci infiniment à tous
peut-être un second seuils de l'actuel
conseil de lecture on peut pas s'en
empêcher nos références quand même
bien sûr le aller sur lequel on s'est
beaucoup appuyé qui s'appelle le procédé
des médecins de nuremberg de bruno
halioua qui est lui-même médecin et qui
permet pour ceux qui le souhaitent et
bien d' approfondir ces questions les
différentes expérimentations menées
et puis ce que deviennent aussi ses
différents accusés et c'est à l'appui
c'est passionnant parce qu'on voit qu'il
ya en effet l'histoire il ya en effet le
problème du droit le pro de médecins et
puis tous les problèmes de la société à
venir
merci infiniment merci merci merci aux
roses et thio merci à xavier paoletti
pardon vous a peut-être pas assez donné
la parole mais on aura l'occasion
peut-être de revenir sur tous ces sujets
bercy infiniment triste
[Musique]